My country saved me.
My country saved me and I cannot forget it.
And I will fight for her as long as I draw
breath so help me God.
The last great active political figure of
the 20th century
has lost his battle with cancer at age 81.
John McCain, former prisoner of war and two
time presidential candidate
was a man propelled by his interpretation
of the honor code
to defy his Vietnamese captors, criticize
Republican politicians including Donald Trump,
and ultimately to support some of the most
interventionist foreign policies
in modern American history.
The namesake son and grandson of well known
navy admirals
McCain initially rebelled against his military
destiny,
famously graduating 894th out of an Annapolis
class of 899.
He drank and cussed, dated Florida strippers
and Brazilian heiresses
and crashed an alarming number of planes before
settling down to the family business of war.
McCain was on the deck of the USS Forrestal
when a stray bomb ignited a fire, killing
134 servicemen
the most deadly accident in US Navy history.
And then the first bomb exploded and this
knocked me about 10 feet
and everyone who had been near me were all
either badly maimed or killed from this explosion.
Yesterday over Hanoi, three American planes
were shot down
and at least two of their pilots captured.
One of them was Lieutenant Commander John
McCain, Third,
the son of the US naval commander in Europe.
I was on a flight over the city of Hanoi and
I was bombing,
I was hit by either a missile or anti-aircraft
fire and I ejected
and broke my leg and both arms
and went into a lake.
The aviator's rebellious nature served him
well over the next five and a half years
as he inspired cellmates with loud acts of
defiance
and quiet organization of internal communication
systems
despite enduring torture that permanently
damaged his body.
This experience combined with the domestic
discord he witnessed upon returning stateside in 1973
damaged his faith in American foreign policy.
Silver Star, Purple Heart, Army Commendation
Medal, eight Air Medals,
national defense and the rest of this garbage
it doesn't mean a thing.
As a congressman McCain opposed Ronald Reagan
sending marines to Beirut.
As a senator he criticized Bill Clinton's
nation building adventures in Somalia and Haiti
and described US military involvement in Yugoslavia
as:
The aspect of the future of this nation that
bothers me more than anything else.
Yet by 1998 McCain would emerge as the Senate's
leading hawk.
So what happened?
The unexpectedly easy military successes in
the Gulf War and Yugoslavia
coupled with the vacuum in post Cold War leadership
led McCain to re-embrace a Teddy Roosevelt
style belief in American military supremacy
and to waive off Vietnam as some sort of anomaly.
"Our loss in Vietnam afflicted America witha
kind of identity crisis"
he wrote in his 1998 memoir 'Faith of my Fathers'
"We should never have let this one mistake,
terrible though it was, color our perceptions forever."
And I thought I would tell Senator McCain
he is a man of profound personal courage
and the suffering in service he gave to this
country ought to be honored.
For most of McCain's political career, he
was the media's favorite Republican.
I admit I, we all rooted for you by the way
and a lot of us in this business like John
McCain a lot.
The wonderful thing about McCain always has
been that he is a maverick.
Hillary Clinton has said that you are her
favorite Republican.
The mutual love affair with what McCain once
described as his base in the national media
soured once he won the Republican nomination.
But even in 2008 the press frequently mistook
his pragmatism for a lack of ideology.
In fact, it was anything but.
The Arizona Senator has long had an alarmingly
martial view of citizenship.
In which individualism must be subsumed to
the greater good.
President Bush has talked about our staying
in Iraq for 50 years.
Maybe a hundred, that'd be fine with me as
long as Americans-
as long as Americans are not being injured
or harmed or wounded or killed.
His longest war was against what he called
corrosive cynicism.
Which meant that anything creating more of
the stuff
from steroids in baseball, to political advertising
on Facebook was in his cross-hairs.
The same sense of high moral dudgeon would
also take him to better places
such as his opposition to torture and annual
attacks on Pentagon waste.
Understandably it's McCain's profound sense
of honor
that obituarists will be emphasizing in the
coming days.
With his health deteriorating in 2017
the Senator led a global tour to reassure
nervous American allies,
called out eruptions of conservative bigotry,
and cast the deciding vote against the flawed
repeal of Obamacare.
Turning the thumbs down on the repeal-
The open ended interventionism the Senator
championed in his final two decades
led to some of the most tragic policy failures
of our time.
There is also honor in seeking a more humble
conception of America's role in the world.
Farewell John McCain.
You will make sacrifices for your fellow Americans
who won't be asked to make sacrifices for
you.
It is a noble cause, it is your cause and
it's worth living and dying for.
May your lives be as lucky as mine, godspeed,
semper fidelis, fair winds and following seas.
Thank you.